does the uk or or our allies allies have
specific intelligence that vladimir
putin is preparing to use chemical
weapons or are we extrapolating this
simply from what he has been saying
well clearly i can't comment on
intelligence the uk government may have
may have received that wouldn't be right
to speak about that publicly but we have
seen in the last 24 or 48 hours what
appear to be
bits of disinformation published by
russian state outlets including in fact
the russian embassy here in london
putting on things like twitter
information that appear to be
creating a false narrative that the
ukrainians are considering
using chemical weapons which is clearly
ridiculous and totally untrue and
sometimes they do that in preparation
but i hope that is that is not what
they're contemplating the use of
chemical weapons again any uh theater of
war but certainly one where there are
lots of civilians totally unacceptable
what we've seen the russians doing in
the last two weeks
in ukraine is totally barbaric we saw
them in the last day or two you know
shelling and bombing hospitals across
ukraine
including a hospital which was where
young mothers were or new mothers were
giving birth to children what they have
done is is totally barbaric which is why
the united kingdom is determined as the
prime minister was saying to do
everything we can to try and stop them
but but in essence if vladimir putin is
willing to bomb a maternity ward he's
willing to do pretty much anything
well i as i say um i'm not going to talk
about intelligence but you know using
chemical weapons in an area which has
lots of civilians would be a barbaric
thing to do and you know i would just
say to to vladimir putin and to the
russian regime you know not to cross
that line not to do that to civilian
populations
let's then talk about that what we heard
yesterday that that finally eventually
um roman abramovich has been has been
sanctioned i'm just wondering i think
many people are wondering this what what
has changed in in the week since the
prime minister accidentally you know you
know misspoke and said that abramovich
was sanctioned when he was and what have
we learned in the past seven days that
has allowed us to move to this position
well the united kingdom of course is a
country which respects the rule of law
we have to go through a proper process
to make sure that everything is done in
a way that's legally waterside people
like abramovic you know have expensive
lawyers and we want to make sure that we
don't get challenged so we've gone
through carefully and methodically
putting together a case that is
watertight and yesterday we acted
against not just abramovic but six other
oligarchs who control critical russian
companies like rossia bank like rosneft
like gazprom these are people oligarchs
and companies who are integral to the
putin regime they're sustaining him
they're supporting him they're enabling
him and it's right that we act against
them as part of our set of measures of
course we've already sanctioned over 300
russian individuals and entities and
those and we've worked with uh other
countries to extend russia from the
swift system but you have to that's
having a big effect you have to accept
that
that any oligarch particularly someone
with the amount the deep pockets of
roman abramovich will have moved assets
out of the country in the days you know
from when it first became mooted that he
would be sanctioned you have to accept
that well i mean there are there are
some asset assets that are hard to move
like chelsea football club that's not
going anywhere and the house uh as far
as you know that hasn't been sold uh and
of course we've also uh done asset
freezes against a number of of big
russian banks we have we've frozen the
assets of about quarter of a trillion
pounds worth of russian bank balance
sheet assets and those were frozen a
while ago and that is more by the way
than the european union it's more than
the united states so those assets have
been frozen for some time now well let's
talk specifically about chelsea first
and foremost you're not a fan are you
i'm a palace fan okay fair enough fair
enough so apologies if a suitable buyer
for chelsea was found is the government
currently minded to allow that deal to
go through yeah so as the license
conditions are written today
the sale would not be allowed however if
a buyer emerged then it would be open to
that buyer or to the football club
to approach the government and ask for
the license conditions to be varied in a
way that allowed that sale to take place
so they'd be they'd be able to approach
the government to make a proposal
but to be clear
no proposal would be accepted which saw
the money the proceeds of any sale
ending up in
an unrestricted bank account owned by
abramovic he can't benefit from the
proceeds of any sale let's talk a little
bit then about about the the ukrainian
refugee crisis and and clearly as a
crisis estimates originally were around
about 2 million people may well be
leaving the country those look to be
doubled the british public is going to
be asked to take in in refugees
themselves just explain a little bit
more about that scheme well it's worth
just talking about the the full spectrum
of our response to the humanitarian
crisis and first of all we've donated
aid uh valued at over 400 million pounds
to help the humanitarian crisis on the
ukrainian border that's more than any
other country in the world and that is
the that is the response that the
ukrainian president principally asked
for and we've met that we've done it
more than any other country
secondly there is a route for fam people
with family members extended family
members in the uk to come over here and
the home secretary announced just
yesterday that where people have family
here and have a ukrainian passport then
we're not going to require them to go
and have biometric checks done which was
a bit of a bottleneck
specifically on the opening of doors so
so thirdly in addition to that we're
going to be making announcements in the
very near future about a scheme for uk
local authorities and indeed uk families
to welcome ukrainian refugees we've
announced that principle and the details
of how that scheme works will be laid
out in the very near future
would you take anyone in to your home i
mean do we know of anyone in the cabinet
that has already suggested that they
might be willing to open their doors
well i think once the details are
published in the very near future
everybody will have a look at that and
see if their personal circumstances
allow them to and uh you know i'm sure
the british public will look at that and
if they're able to some people will be
able to and some won't they'll they'll
make their own their own decisions
just before we let you go just closer to
your briefing in fact we've been hearing
uh overnight indeed yesterday facebook
um has made a temporary
exception as they're describing it to
those that have been affected by war in
essence allowing them on their platform
to call for violence against russia
something which facebook would not allow
in any other circumstances are you
entirely sanguine with that
well i haven't seen the details of that
announcement so i'm slightly reluctant
to comment on uh what is what that
proposal without having seen the details
what i do know is that the russian
government have been trying to block
various social media platforms
from operating in russia as part of
their disinformation campaign to try and
essentially trick the russian people
they're lying to the russian people
about what is happening because if the
russian people realize the full extent
of the atrocities being committed by
putin in their name they would be
extremely angry and that is why putin is
trying to hide that from his own
population i understand this is
developing well we haven't have had a
statement from facebook's parent
organization meta they say these are
temporary measures designed to preserve
voice and expression for people who are
facing invasion as always we are
prohibiting calls for violence against
russians outside of the narrow context
of the current invasion it's a narrow
context but again i'm just wondering how
you feel about one of the big tech
giants in essence allowing people to
call for violence against russians in a
way which we would probably not be
allowed to do in the streets of the uk
well i think it sounds like they're
talking about specifically in ukraine
and obviously ukrainian the ukrainian
army and ukrainian citizens have every
right to defend their homeland to defend
their cities and their towns to defend
their hospitals against this aggression
by russia and to be honest if somebody
was attacking croydon the place i
represent if somebody was bombing
croydon university hospital i tell you
what i would be in the streets defending
my hospital i'd be in the streets
defending my town and my neighbours as
ukrainians are quite rightly doing